#ReleaseTheMemo.
ALL OF THAT INTO NIGHTS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT CONTINUES.
THE TRUTH ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION IS BEING EXPOSED
AS A SHAM.
A DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL
MUELLER SO-CALLED INVESTIGATION
IS BASED AND PREDICATED ON A Y
AND A CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT WAS
COOKED UP BY THE OBAMA
THAT WAS NEVER SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN.
RUSSIA.
TRUMP.
RUSH APPEARED COLLUSION.
THE ONLY EVIDENCE WE DO HAVE
TONIGHT IS THAT HILLARY CLINTON
RUSSIAN LIES TO TRY AND
INFLUENCE ALL OF YOU DURING THAT
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHAT MUELLER SHOULD
REALLY BE LOOKING INTO.
POLITICAL HIT JOB TO REMOVE A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE AND USE THE POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE AND THE
FISA COURTS TO DO IT.
NOW IS MORE DAMAGING INFORMATION
COMING OUT EVERY DAY, IT LOOKS
THEY ARE TRYING NOW TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE WITH THEIR LAME
STREAM MEDIA FRIENDS WITH
NOT WORTHY OF YOUR ATTENTION,
UNLESS YOU WORK FOR THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA.
BEFORE WE GET TO TONIGHT'S NEW
INFORMATION.
HE GAVE THOSE MEMOS TO THE
COLUMBIA PROFESSOR FOR THE VERY
PURPOSE OF LEAKING TO THE PRESS
THAT A SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD BE
APPOINTED, HOPING THAT THIS
WOULD ALL COME TO PASS.
COMEY ALSO REPORTEDLY
THAT SOUNDS LIKE COLLUSION.
IN SPITE OF THESE FACTS, THE
MARTYR, AS HE RECENTLY TWEETED.
GO TO REPORTS OR PEOPLE STANDING
NOT WHERE HE STANDS IN MOMENTS
OF COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE BUT
WHERE HE STANDS IN TIMES OF
CHALLENGE AND CONTROVERSY.
WAIT A MINUTE?
HE PUT THE FIXING SO HILLARY
WOULDN'T BE CHARGED IN SPITE OF
THE EVIDENCE HE KNEW EXISTED.
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT, AND
NATIONAL DISGRACE, AND BEYOND
LAUGHABLE.
HE DESERVED TO BE FIRED.
WE WILL EXPLAIN WHY IN A MINUTE.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE MORE
EVIDENCE OF JUST HOW FRAUDULENT,
UNETHICAL, AND NEFARIOUS MOLARS
INVESTIGATION REALLY IS.
HERE ARE THE NEW TEXTS RELEASED
ON MAY 19TH, 2 DAYS AFTER ROBERT
NOTHING.
IF I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKELY, I'D
GUT SENSE AND CONCERN IS NO BIG
THEY THERE-THERE.
MANY TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
STRZOK WAS A HIGH-RANKING
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL AT THE FBI
THE SPECIALIZED AND RUSSIA,
SIGNED THE PAPERWORK TO START
THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
KNOWING THERE IS NO THERE-THERE.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
A HOAX.
THIS PROVES IT.
IT'S PART OF AN ATTEMPT TO STOP
TRUMP FROM WINNING AND REMOVING
HIM FROM OFFICE.
WE NEVER SHOULD HAVE GONE DOWN
HACKS AND THE MEDIA, CNN, MSNBC,
EVERY BROADCAST CHANNEL,
"WASHINGTON POST," THEY HAVE
BEEN GIVING YOU NOTHING BUT LIES
AND PROPAGANDA NOW FOR A YEAR.
COMMITTED ARE NOW TRYING TO
COVER IT UP.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET AWAY
WITH IT.
WHEN EVERYTHING IS SAID AND
DONE, THIS IS GOING TO MAKE
WATERGATE LOOK LIKE A KIDS
STEALING CANDY FROM A STORE.
WE REPORTED YESTERDAY, FIVE
MONTHS OF TEXT MESSAGES ARE
MISSING BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED DURING THIS
CRITICAL TIME FRAME.
CLAIMED THAT THERE WERE
RIGHT HERE ON THIS PROGRAM.
THEN BUS FEED PUBLISHED THE
STORY THAT IS AT FIVE MISSING
MONTHS THAT CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PLAYED FOR THE DOSSIER.
THAT WAS IN JANUARY PETE ALDA
SAID IN THE TEXT STOP.
THAT WAS USED IN PART AND LATER
ON TO GET THE VISOR WANT TO SPY
ON THE TRIM CAMPAIGN.
WHAT WOULD LUCK HABIT, IT WAS
PETER STRZOK WHO ACTUALLY WAS
THE OFFICIAL THAT OVERSAW THAT
THEN ON MAY 17TH, ROBERT MUELLER
WAS NAMED A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THOSE ARE THE MAJOR EVENTS, AND
HOW CONVENIENTLY, IT HAPPENS IS
THAT THE MESSAGES, SOME 50,000
OF THEM, THIS IS THE TIME.
PERIOD
WHERE STRZOK AND PAGE HEIGHT
BACK 'S WERE MISSING.
THEY'S BLADE ON SAMSUNG WHO
SUPPLIED THE PHONES.
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING ME.
IT'S THE FBI WHO SPECIALIZES IN
INTELLIGENCE AND GATHERING.
THEY CAN'T FIND THE MESSAGES?
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S POSSIBLE.
GIVING THE INHERENT ANTITRUST
BIAS THAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
STRZOK AND PAGE, THEY HATED
TRUMP, AND THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN
TALKING ABOUT DURING THESE FIVE
CRITICAL MONTHS, THE FBI
SHOULD FIND THOSE MESSAGES,
MAYBE MAKE A CALL TO SAMSUNG.
IF YOU CAN GET IT, I BET THEY
CAN.
THERE'S ALSO STUNNING NEW
REVELATION TONIGHT ABOUT THESE
MISSING TEXT MESSAGES.
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY IS SAYING
THERE IS A MESSAGE BETWEEN
STRZOK AND PAGE ABOUT DELETING
THESE TEXT CONVERSATIONS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP FOR A
NOVEL.
A LOOK AT THIS NEW INFORMATION.
WORLD'S PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY SOMEHOW MISSED.
TODAY WAS A TEXT ABOUT NOT
KEEPING TAXES.
WE SAW MORE MANIFEST BRYANT'S
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THE ELECTION INTO
THE TRANSITION.
>> Sean: HATRED AGAINST TRUMP,
THAT SOUNDS LIKE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE ALL SEEN THIS HAPPEN.
EVERY SINGLE SOLITARY TIME THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
OFFICIALS ARE BACKED INTO A
CORNER AND IN SERIOUS LEGAL
TROUBLE, ALL OF THE EVIDENCE
MAGICALLY DISAPPEARS.
THIS IS THEIR OPERAND I.
HILLARY CLINTON 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS DELETED.
JUST TO MAKE EXTRA EXTRA SURE,
ACID WATCH BLEACH DATE, THE
WHOLE ENTIRE CAR DRIVE TO MAKE
SURE THE EVIDENCE IS COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
IN CASE IT MADE IT TO ANY OF THE
MOBILE DEVICES, THEY SEND AND
ATE OUT WITH A HAMMER.
BOOM!
LET'S MATCH THAT SUCKER.
THE ONLY PHONES I GAVE THE FBI,
THEY HAD NO SAME CARDS.
I'M SURE IT WAS JUST AN
ACCIDENT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
A BRIDGE TO NOWHERE.
THERE'S ALSO THE IRS CAN
TARGETING CONSERVATIVES.
THE EMAIL FROM CORRUPT
OFFICIALS.
THEY DISAPPEARED FOR TWO YEARS.
THE IRS CLAIMED AT THE TIME THEY
WERE LOST BECAUSE OF A SYSTEM
CRASH.
WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ AND THE
PREDICTABLY, THEY DENIED IT
HAPPEN.
THERE'S EVEN MORE NEW
INFORMATION TONIGHT.
WE WILL BE GIVING IT TO YOU
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSMAN JOHN
RATCLIFFE, STRZOK AND PAGE WERE
ALSO TALKING ABOUT, IMAGINE THIS
ALSO TALKING ABOUT, IMAGINE THI
THIS, A SECRET SOCIETY MEETING
THE DAY AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
WON THE ELECTION.
WHOSE IN THE SECRET SOCIETY?
COULD IT BE PAGE?
STRZOK?
BRUCE OHR?
SOCIETY?
ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE LEARNED TODAY ABOUT
INFORMATION THAT AFTER AN
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
ELECTIONS, THERE MAY HAVE BEEN A
SECRET SOCIETY OF FOLKS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FBI TO INCLUDE PAGE AND STRZOK
THAT WOULD BE WORKING AGAINST
FOLK SPEAK IN THOSE TERMS, THEY
NEED TO COME FORWARD TO EXPLAIN
THE CONTACTS IN WHICH THEY SPOKE
THOSE TERMS.
>> Sean: THEY SAID THERE'S NO
CONCRETE EVIDENCE YET THAT THE
SECRET SOCIETY EVER MET.
HERE'S WHAT WE DO KNOW.
STRZOK AND PAGE AND WHO WE THINK
IS A DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE WERE MEETING ABOUT THE
INSURANCE POLICY, JUST IN CASE
HILLARY LOSSY ELECTION.
ALL OF THE OTHER EVIDENCE POINTS
TO ONE SIMPLE FACT.
TOP RANKING OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
THEY PROTECTED HILLARY CLINTON
FROM PROSECUTION.
THEN THEY USE THAT PHONY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER THAT HILLARY BOUGHT PAID
FOUR FULL OF RUSSIAN SALACIOUS
WISE TO GO AFTER THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TO TRY AND INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION.
AS WE HAVE NOW BEEN SAYING FOR
MONTHS, THE FIX WAS IN AND THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
WHY?
THEY WANTED HILLARY TO RUN AND
DIDN'T WANT TRUMP TO WIN.
HERE'S ANOTHER TEXT MESSAGE FROM
LORETTA LYNCH, THEY ALL KNEW
THAT WOULDN'T BE PROSECUTED.
PARTICIPANTS AND ALL OF THIS,
THEY DIDN'T DO THE
INVESTIGATION.
REMEMBER IN MAY, JAMES COMEY AND
PETER STRZOK, AND OTHER TOP FBI
OFFICIALS, THEY WERE DRAFTING
THE EXONERATION OF HILLARY
MONTHS BEFORE THEY EVER
HOW CAN YOU ACTUALLY EXONERATE
SOMEONE TO BE FOREVER TO THEM?
THAT'S CALLED THE FIX IT BEING
IN.
THAT'S BEING READ.
THAT IS CORRUPTION 101.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT JAMES
COMEY, DENYING UNDER OATH THAT
HE REACHED HIS LEGAL CONCLUSION
BEFORE HILLARY CLINTON.
WE HAVE ALL THE DIFFERENT DRAFTS
ALL POINTING TOWARD A CASE OF
HILLARY BEING GUILTY.
WATCH THIS.
>> DIRECTOR, DID YOU MAKE THE
DECISION NOT TO RECOMMEND
CRIMINAL CHARGES RELATED TO
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION BEFORE OR
AFTER HILLARY CLINTON WAS
>> AFTER.
DECISION, PLEASE URGE THEM TO
CONTACT ME PRIVATELY SO WE CAN
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
THE DECISION WAS MADE AFTER THAT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
INTERVIEW.
SHE MAY BE ALLIED IN THE
INTERVIEW DURING THE WAY WE
COULD PREPARE TO BE WHAT I WILL
CALL YOUR NUMBER.
I HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR
YOU.
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE COMEY LIED
UNDER OATH.
WE KNOW WE HAD THE DRAFTS AND
TONIGHT JUST BREAKING, POLITICAL
REPORTING THAT CONGRESSMAN
RATCLIFF IS SAYING THAT HE WANTS
TO INTERVIEW COMEY AGAIN UNDER
OATH ABOUT ALL THESE
INCONSISTENCIES IN HIS PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE TIMELINE.
AT THE END OF JUNE 2016,
BILL CLINTON DECIDES TO MEET
LORETTA LYNCH ON THE TARMAC FOR
THEN ON JULY 1ST, LYNCH SAYS
SHE'S GOING TO STEP AWAY FROM
THE INVESTIGATION.
SHE WILL ACCEPT WHATEVER THE FBI
CONCLUDES.
SHE ENCOURAGED COMEY IT'S A
MATTER, IT'S ON AN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS ALL BEFORE
HILLARY CLINTON, THREE DAYS
BEFORE SHE WAS EVER EVEN
INTERVIEWED, THAT HAVE BEEN ON
THE FOURTH OF JULY WEEKEND.
AFTER LYNCH'S STATEMENT THAT SHE
WAS TAKING A BACKSEAT, STRZOK
PAGE ROOM SAYS THAT IS AWFUL
SINCE SHE KNOWS NO CHARGES WILL
BE BROUGHT.
THEY HAD AN INTERVIEW -- HAD AN
HILLARY CLINTON APPEARED FOUR
DAYS LATER THEY FINALLY
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON T
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON E
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON I
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON D
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON Y
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON ON .
MAY AND HIS PRESS CONFERENCE,
GIVING HILLARY CLINTON A PASS ON
EVERYTHING.
PAGING APPEARS.
STRZOK KNEW.
COMEY KNEW.
LYNCH KNOW.
I ASSUME McCABE KNEW AS WELL.
IF LISA PAGE KNEW, THEN THAT
PROBABLY MEANS SHE WAS ADVISING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE.
WHAT ELSE ARE THEY LYING ABOUT?
WERE THEY AWARE OF THE FBI IS
GIVING CLINTON COVER?
IF COMEY, AND ALL THE TOP LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS NEW THAT
THIS WAS THEIR AGREEMENT TO NOT
GO AFTER CLINTON BECAUSE THEY
WANTED HER IN THE RACE TO DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE THEY KNOW
BETTER THAN YOU WHO SHOULD BE
PRESIDENT, THEN IT'S A PRETTY
DARN GOOD CHANCE THAT SOMEBODY
IN THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE ALSO
WAS DOING THE WINK AND NOD
THING, AND THEY KNEW THE FIX WAS
IN.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE FIX WAS IN.
IT WASN'T RIGGED.
THERE IS ANOTHER COMPONENT TO
THE STORY.
WE HAVE EVEN MORE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT ABOUT THE EFFORT BY
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS TO
RELEASE THE FOUR-PAGE CLASSIFIED
MEMO.
NEARLY 200 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
HAVE NOW SEEN THIS AND FOX NEWS
IS REPORTING TONIGHT THAT THE
MEMO COULD BE RELEASED ANY DAY
NOW.
WE ARE STILL CALLING ON YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, ONCE AGAIN.
CALL UP YOUR MEMBER OF CONGRESS
AND DEMAND THAT THE RELEASE.
RELEASE THE MEMO.
CALL THE NUMBER AT THE BOTTOM OF
YOUR SCREEN.
TELL YOUR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
WE DESERVE TO KNOW THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHAT IS LIKELY THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THERE IS SO MUCH INFORMATION.
SO MANY PLAYERS INVOLVED IN ALL
HILLARY CLINTON RIGGED THE
PRIMARY.
IF YOU ARE BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTER, YOU SHOULD BE -- WHY
YOU'RE NOT?
I DON'T KNOW.
EVEN THOUGH IT THERE IS A
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE THAT
SHE BROKE THE LAW, JAMES COMEY,
ANDREW McCABE, PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, LORETTA LYNCH, I'LL
THEY IGNORE THE RULE OF LAW, THE
CONSTITUTION, AND CLINTON AND
THE DNC THAT SHE CONTROLS SPEND
OVER $12 MILLION TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION WITH A BOUGHT AND
SHIPPED OFF TO COMPLIANT MEDIA.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WEAPONIZE THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE NEED TO
KEEP OUR COUNTRY SAFE, BUT IN
THIS CASE, THEY USED IT TO
TARGET MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THIS, SO YOU UNDERSTAND, IS SO
MUCH BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
IT'S ABOUT OUR CONSTITUTION,
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
IT IS BEEN SHREDDED.
ALL BECAUSE POWERFUL PEOPLE AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL IN THE DOJ AND
THE FBI THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
THAN YOU, AS TO WHO SHOULD BE
PRESIDENT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SERIOUS
RAMIFICATIONS IF WE ARE GOING TO
SAVE OUR COUNTRY IN ALL OF THIS.
PEOPLE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE,